Israel's tourism minister is in Saudi
Arabia to attend a United Nations
conference on world tourism himim cat's
two-day visit to Riyad comes as Saudi
Arabia is pursuing a possible us broker
deal to formalize relations normalize
relations between the two countries
let's get more from our correspondent
Rob Reynolds who's joining us from
occupied East Jerusalem so tell us about
the significance of the visit by the
Israeli Minister Su to Saudi Arabia
Rob
well F uh at least part of the
significance is that this has never
happened before uh there has never been
a Israeli Minister uh who has gone to uh
Saudi Arabia on an in an official
capacity uh in a public capacity uh and
so that that is an evidence that this uh
us brokered effort at a rap rosmont
between Israel and Saudi Arabia is
moving forward and we've just learned
some breaking news really just in the
past few minutes is uh from uh Israeli
Army Radio saying that the
communications minister of Israel will
also visit the Saudi Kingdom next week
so uh taken together that's another sign
and on top of that just today uh the
Saudis sent what they are calling their
ambassador to Palestine to rala uh in
the OCC Ed territories of West uh the
West Bank where he met with the
Palestinian president Mahmud abas we
don't know exactly what they discuss but
you could see that uh quite possibly as
a gesture on the part of the Saudis to
tell the Palestinians that they're not
going to get short shrift out of this uh
normalization deal if it does go forward
yeah and we'll have more on the Saudi
delegation's visit to romala in just a
few minutes with Maita Ibrahim who's
there for us I wanted to ask you rob how
does the
Palestinian uh Palestinians how do they
fit in uh into the US broker efforts to
to normalize relations between Israel
and Saudi
Arabia well you know that that is the
biggest question really uh for the
Palestinians and for you know it's
something that that this whole deal
could hinge upon let's recall that back
in 2002 the Saudis actually said they
would normalize relations with Israel
but Israel had to commit first to an
independent Palestinian State uh based
on the pre-1967 borders with its capital
in Jerusalem here we are 21 years later
and the Saudis and the Israelis are
moving forward apparently at a pretty
good clip uh in their negotiations and
there's been nothing said po uh uh
publicly uh or concretely about what
might happen with the Palestinians now
uh it's also important to note that the
government of Benjamin Netanyahu the
prime minister of Israel is composed of
ultr nationalist parties who are
adamantly opposed to any kind of
Palestinian state in any of the occupied
territories and of course that's been
kind of the driving theme of netanyahu's
long political career as well so it
remains to be seen uh what the uh
Palestinians would get out of this deal
but many Palestinians are afraid that it
might go forward without receiving any
without them receiving any concrete
political benefits thank you rob for
that Rob uh Reynolds live there in
occupied East Jerusalem